i went away on a vacation with my wife
my parents his grandparents came to stay
the weekend
when we got the directv bill the next
month there was porn on the direct tv
bill
he
blames my parents
now hold on hold on before we get
started round of applause
people who think
my parents
ordered the part
thank you wait wait
wait stop stop
why are you choosing to believe a then
16 year old teenager who wants to stick
his dick in a light socket over my
[ __ ] grown adult parents i don't
understand why i i can't even believe it
wait can we go back yeah who says is a
16 year old i'm sticking my dick in a
light socket i just want to go back to
that real quick hold on i mean you know
saying
what's there's a saying
this is the worst thing about and this
is
about this whole story is i'll never
know the truth
because i said
i said to my dad i said to my dad i go
hey
did you
and he goes
wait has jacob not said anything
and i go no and he goes well then i'm
not gonna and i was like what
okay you know what's best about that
though this [ __ ]
you know first of all
tom wolf's savage and that's
forever second of all you know what's
the best part about that though is he
now know well he knows and everybody
knows as he's explained earlier he goes
for the joke and everything right so
he's gonna go for whatever makes him
laugh
grandpa now knows that and you know what
he's doing whether he did it or not
[ __ ] he did he's [ __ ] with you
he's taken it to a level of well well
this is now funny to me and everybody
else except you so i'm just gonna let it
run out
and just walks out the [ __ ] door held
on i really i love that my dad threw
that in there i mean what a dick move
but i
love it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]